O!Sapiens Expert: Хэллоу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так нажде Я тебя не слышу. Скажи. Еще раз что, нибудь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Раз, два, три, как, слышно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот теперь слышу отличный. Да, Ты, мне как?
Tamaz Gadaev: Хорошо, слышно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, супер готова дам!
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Удоб меня, как обычно. Начнем пусть небольшого отдыхать на упражнения.
O!Sapiens Expert: Откинь. Сюда в стройцеподобне что, ода. Закрыл глаза сделай глубокий. Вдох до понады. Легких.
O!Sapiens Expert: Следовал старой догоняющий?
O!Sapiens Expert: Плавно вдыхая воздух из легких заметь ощущения, в теле мысли эмоции переживания, все, что Происходит сейчас, внутри, да Этому. Просто.
O!Sapiens Expert: Пространство, Чтоб быть Никак, не меняем. Его. Второй. Глубокий, вдох?
O!Sapiens Expert: Невтора. Догоняющие?
O!Sapiens Expert: Медленно, плавно, вдыхая?
O!Sapiens Expert: Замечаем ощущения в теле в сторону все. Тревоги все. Заботы все. Проекты все, мысли, которые не, касаются этого разговором?
O!Sapiens Expert: Индион, Третья, завершающий глубокий долг?
O!Sapiens Expert: Некоторые, догоняющий?
O!Sapiens Expert: Именно плавно выдыхаю возвращаемся, В ощущение в теле вообщении, кожи с, пригострением с одеждой ощущения, гравитации, тяжести тела, как, ноги, ощущают?
O!Sapiens Expert: Воздух. И когда готов можно, открыть глаза?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что сегодня будет Конденсированная сессия. На прошлом.
O!Sapiens Expert: В нашем звонке мы. С тобой говорили про очень интересную составляющую которую хочется, затронуть говорил что ты прочувствовал. Вот, этот аспект того, когда ты спишь по четыре часа и это всказывается, на твоей продуктивности на том как ты себя чувствуешь, и, так далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: Уровне, энтузиазма ученности, способности, чувствовать где, то может, быть излучает энергию, радоваться победам, и так далее?
O!Sapiens Expert: При этом, мы с. Тобой. Какое то время назад говорили про то что, у, тебя не было каких то. Объективных показателей или доказательных базы того, что сон, как то сказывается на продуктивность и, вот. Здесь мы толком не проговорили но, хочется здесь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Понять, как, для тебя сейчас когда, ты, это прочувствовал все же, когда вот этот недосып сказывается?
O!Sapiens Expert: Каковой тебе с этим?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сравнении с теоретической базой, которой ну вроде бы что, то как, то сказывается Когда ты почувствовал какого?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что то, поменялось?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но я, стал еще больше замечать?
Tamaz Gadaev: В общем, по мне стало больше бить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я стал больше, про то, думать, когда я все таки недосыпаюч. Это происходит.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, вчера такое было?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, я что то вчера, еще прям мне. Было, грустно короче, было, какая. То апатия что такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот тоже был. Какой то недосып, здесь, но здесь он как, бы он короче он?
Tamaz Gadaev: Здесь уже проще. Нормально. Ложится. Спать. Сильно.
Tamaz Gadaev: В смысле, вечером, ничего, не происходит?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вся среда для этого есть но, Я просыпаюсь счастье по в шесть тридцать утра?
Tamaz Gadaev: И?
Tamaz Gadaev: Бывает, если я поздно уснул?
Tamaz Gadaev: На Следующий день я, чувствую снова осонливость вот Мне Еще Сонливость?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Первох санливость во вторых апатичное настроения, я сразу. Такой боля так. Не. Надо было делать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Надлично?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Короче, да вот, этот негативный сигнал короче, который, который, должен быть онщищается лучше смысле, я. Его?
Tamaz Gadaev: Лучше. Замечаю, что ли?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер! Поздравляю! Как, Ты, Что на меняешь, в свете этого?
O!Sapiens Expert: Или пока просто на уровне. Замечания.
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Я, стараюся раньше ложиться спать тут возникают другие?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Как, Бы тут какой, есть конфликт да? Что? Типа, есть, долгосрочная часть которая, ну, смысли, рациональная, более которая понимает, что я могу завтра быть там не таким продуктивным, не таким, веселым, и так далее.
Tamaz Gadaev: А в моменте, когда вот уже пора спать либо либо, есть, какая то история что, мне нужно доработать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я не хочу завтра приходить на амид типа, с пустыми, с пустыми результатами это такая что ли. Ну. Или не с пустыми а, с недостаточными что. Ли. Какая То поддавливание, какого, то, социального такого такой, Штуки типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Какая, то стыд или что это такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: И второе, это когда что то очень увлекает. Ты Вроде, не, хочешь спать прям сильно тебя? Не Рубят?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но ну хочется, что, то еще поделать хочется. Полежать в компее вот. Как то дожить что, день?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, но это очень знакомая мне штука смысли что, вот, эти две два основных?
Tamaz Gadaev: Основные. Два. Чувства или состояния которые, меня вечером?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не дают мне нормально поспать. Скажем. Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Либо желание что, то делать по работе либо желание дожить, день как то вот как, то, кайфануть, что ли?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гм?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Ну, Сейчас, кажется, проявляется, вот, это. Новое составляющее, да которая уже, начинает замечать что сон, сказывается, и здесь еще. Хочется уточнить по поводу вот. Этой Знакомой части которая тебе говорит про то, что хочется?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что это делать? По работе какие? Моменты она условно успокаивается в, какие актуализируются?
Tamaz Gadaev: Успокаивается, когда, результат есть когда, вот какой то какой, то какая, то, дельта как, бы по работе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Проблема в том что, это дельта ну тут. Это, ком. Типа, вот вчера например. Мне, Было, очень, тяжело, собраться поработать я начал работать там, типа, в шесть вечера или что, такое. Или в, семь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Потому что до этого было очень мало, сил было. Сонливость я. Се Там вытаскивал всякими разными способами это не знаю там. Дышал, медитировал.
Tamaz Gadaev: В душ ходил гулял короче, кучу всего, Делал, просто, чтобы восстановиться по, состоянию?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот потом остановился, и ну, я, вчера, успел, что, то сделать Типа Норм это, не сильно в поздно ушло?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Да, Это, обычно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не хочется приходить засутствием результата.
Tamaz Gadaev: И я думаю, что это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну? Вот есть такой феллор Молт Короче. Что, если, я думаю что, я за сегодня ничего не сделал?
Tamaz Gadaev: То зафиксировать прибыль вернеубыток Неприятно Он еще. Социальный потому, что, я работаю в команде?
Tamaz Gadaev: И как руководитель, и всяко такое не хочется общем приходить в команде горишь чуть я Него эни. Сделал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, здесь есть два моменты, на которых хочу остановится первый это. Ты. Сказал что, вчера был такой обсложенный день сонливости все застрялся работа врем шести Часов а, это. Связано с недосыпом. Как, раз. Мало сна было. Ли. Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Да, я думаю, что с недосыпом. Плюс с накопившимся недосыпым, плюс, там, еще одна эмоциональная штука произошла у меня там. Ну. Типа, два. Дня назад Я, Думал что, там след, и ее тоже догоняли?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Да, Ну, Супер?
O!Sapiens Expert: Главное зарегистрирует для своей нервной системы то, как, недосы сказывается это сейчас очень. Важно. Этот переходный период. А второй момент который еще, хотел спросить по поводу того что, ну, там фиксируешь убыток это понятно а. Вот. Эти. Моменты когда условно говоря ты сделал, это как вот мы тогда обсуждали три из десяти?
O!Sapiens Expert: Или это, сколько?
O!Sapiens Expert: Случаев?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ощущение, когда не сделал?
O!Sapiens Expert: И нет. Вот когда ты сделал когда, вот типа нормально сегодня, можно раслабиться я. Типа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сделал все, что надо было. Это. Вот в трех из десяти случаев или, это с какой частотой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Час уже меньше на сам деле. Это потому, что я остался я больше прощать когда, че, то они, сделал?
Tamaz Gadaev: А части. Ну. Хотя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Короче, тут, тут есть его такой момент первое что.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня не совсем также. Распределено время как, у инженеров?
Tamaz Gadaev: Потому что возникают в какие то штуки внезапны, у меня больше синков, там, и всяк такое много задач связанных, там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Организационных. Давай, так, скажем?
Tamaz Gadaev: При этом я продолжаю инженерить. И как была штука Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Была как бы такая ошибка.
Tamaz Gadaev: Может быть, и не ошибка.
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, я брал какие. То блоки ну ключевые инженерные? Штуки, Которые, нужно это, типа делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: И мое время, менее детерминировано и брать ключевые штуки которые блокают других людей не очень прикольно потому, что о, чем не возник нет?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня с больше вирядностью счета возникли чем у других людей. Это правильно. Делегировать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но как быгая сторона этого что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Моя, задача типа, вкладывать тем что, я, умею максимально в самое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Самые тонкие, точки?
Tamaz Gadaev: Стартапа типа. Не Важно что, это это инженерка, это не, инженерка то, если, есть место куда нужно, вложиться и сейчас нет человека, который лучше всего туда вложиться то, я туда вкладюсь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот и поэтому иногда критичные блоки нужно брать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да. Ну. В общем и, здесь, Вот это вот, история про. Три из десяти оно иногда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы я иногда все это прощаю. Смесле такой, блядь но у меня было много полезных тасок, а иногда?
Tamaz Gadaev: А иногда, ну, от, когда, особенно это происходит из за?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда у меня нет оправдания перед собой нормального почему. Не Почему? Я не сделал что, то полезно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот оправдание перед собою ну скорее Это, Оправдание Перед внешним миром скорее так.
Tamaz Gadaev: Это не перед собой о. Сам, деле?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тогда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, тогда это чувство возникает, что типаблиоте. Я там, что то не доделал.
O!Sapiens Expert: Слушать Такой вопрос. Ты, Говоришь, про оправдание перед собой но на сам, деле, перед внешним миром тебя хоть. Раз. Кто. То просил объясняться?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что еще раз?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тебя хоть раз хоть, кто то просил объясняться за?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: То, что ты считаешь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Уга?
O!Sapiens Expert: А от куда это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но это, но это набор такой внутренних установок, что Ли или стандартов Или Вот что, то такое как, я себе представляю чтоб, что было бы в идеале. Давай так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Потому, что, ну, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тесть может быть, как это прямолинейно. Но тебе. Этот набор установок и стандарт. Вообще, как тебе, кажется, суммарно, больше помогает или?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ня он определенно. Помогает. Во Многих местах в смысле что это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но определенно помогает вопрос как, это общий сумма.
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, я и думаю, что суммарно тоже. Ну. Не, Знаю, тут нужно, их, разделить, давай так это. Как вот вай фай когда. Собой. Типа обзаришь если есть, какая, то, часть которая?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тебе. В опреленных моментах. Приносит вред.
Tamaz Gadaev: Ты Нужно Ее Поблагодарить за то почему она, такая, получилась родилась и? Что Она, тебе дала и так далее, но Я Определенно чувствую если, давай, так как, я к этому отношусь типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Моя, Задача в, том числе в стартапе, пушать и тип остальных людей и, себя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужна. Скорость высокая, и, все прочее?
Tamaz Gadaev: Успевать, к сроку вещи делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там жертвать собой где, то я опять же. Это от, команды, требуется в. Том. Числе, типа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: И в какие то моменты это очень сильно помогает.
O!Sapiens Expert: Гм?
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда ну Нужно, сесть, навалится всех дружно типа, и быстро Что, то. Вырулить и вот. Сейчас такой момент еще один надвигается, кажется, к следующему четвергу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот А с другой стороны есть, моменты в, которых это не, помогает там где, ну, типа, оставь, этот. Час Два работы, которые ты там поделаешь вечером пять, сделаешь, завтра?
Tamaz Gadaev: С более более энергично то, Есть там, очевидно когда, то чувство которое, толкает к пушу может, быть использует, вот. Это Вот.
Tamaz Gadaev: Внутренний стандарт по теплу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужно быть примером для других?
Tamaz Gadaev: Е?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы это работать? Часто я получаю в качестве федбэка что, Типа? Круто, что Ты вот пример такой?
Tamaz Gadaev: И это работает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что нужно успевать к срокам вещи?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что, нужно, если закаметился нужно сделать, это, какая, то надежность?
Tamaz Gadaev: Даже если там, что то не так пошло?
Tamaz Gadaev: В общем этого, такие наборнутельных стандартов, которые?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вызывает чувство, которое меня заставляет. Что это сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Оно иногда ложно положительное в смысле что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там, где оно, не нужно, и где оно будет вредно, например, там, где мне, нужно восстановиться. И завтра. Нормально поебашать.
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужна. Ну, норма. Поспать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, и вот это Доложно Положительное срабатывание этого чувства. Оно Нет, позитив, Я бы сказал, но оно, как бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Правильный подход. Наверно, при возникновении этого чувства, классифицировать оно ложно положительное, сейчас или, или, неложно положительно но, это. Бывает тяжело сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но вот вчера, я мог это сделать. Больше?
O!Sapiens Expert: Спасибо, Вчера Ты, мог это сделать потому, что, ты, понял последствия?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, потому что есть, как очевидные ситуации, И даже такой класс ситуации, в которая попадаю, когда ну, типа, лишние два часа. Работы.
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне нужно не сказать что, этот духу я результата. Но отнимут завтрашнюю концентрацию. На тридцать процентов типа?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, И это хуе?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так, мы сейчас начинаем подбираться, к чему то, очень интересному то есть. Ты, говоришь. Что, нет, позитив при этом. Там все равно замечая что, там порой эти два часа работы они все, же дополнительно бывают и они сказываются на. Минус, тридцати процентов продуктивности?
O!Sapiens Expert: При этом, у нас если я правильно понимаю, в этой же логике только в. Трех из десяти случаев есть условно говоря удовлетворенность где, семь, это все, же не удовлетворенности и создания какого то, дополнительного, не знаю может, стресс фактора или, какого, то, внутреннего напряжения, Если Чего то, не было?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот по поводу трех и семей. Я вот не знаю на, сам деле как, бот я. Сейчас это. Охарактеризовал что, с тех пор довольно много поменялось на сам деле?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас Я города более чел мне. Кажется, Почасти?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Не, Гораздо, но сколько, то, но точно?
O!Sapiens Expert: На сколько?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но сейчас. По большому количеству треков. Все хорошо. В стартапе.
Tamaz Gadaev: Поэтому не знаю шестьдесят на сорок а где. Шестьдесят. Это это все ок?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может питань?
O!Sapiens Expert: Бэт. Звик?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну То, есть стояла супер, супер амбициозна задача которая! Хуй по. Име, как, можно, было выполнить, она по большей части? Была моей ответственностью. Мы Ее выполнили?
Tamaz Gadaev: Возникла другая, какая то задача такая, же но вот то, что там все хорошо. Я такое, заебись.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: То есть, но, это конечно, зависит сильно. От от внешнего мира.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, здесь. Конечно, опасность Если у тебя окружающая, среда внешнего мира она тебя условно загоняет, в ситуацию где, вечный, пожар и все плохо то, к, чему это может привести?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Вот, уже не вечное пожары в смысле вот я, Игорю сейчас стало получше потому что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как это видишь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Периодами. В смысле, что бывает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Возникает какая то необходимость очень много впихнуть работы, и сделать то, что сделать, невозможно Как бы казалось, бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Ты, все сильно включаешься сильно стресуешь, там, типа, заебываешься, и, так далее.
Tamaz Gadaev: Может быть, ну, много, лишнего фрикшена есть в. Этом заебе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Выполняется, и все этот зает, проходит?
Tamaz Gadaev: Потом возникает новый заемка через какое то, время?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я бы сказал, так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. То есть Если, оценивать, опять же вот, это, пра?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот это полезность Этих установок Я думают, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: То, что они в целом есть. Это хорошо.
Tamaz Gadaev: Но там бывает вот ложно положительное, срабатывание когда, они включаются там где, им, не, нужно включаться?
Tamaz Gadaev: Из внутри. Это оценить сложно но, можно. Если, включить осознность?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как оценить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Вот, у, меня такой приходит в голову мысль что типа.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Если я заметил, это, нужно отложить, ноут, сесть, закрыть глаза и, с собой поговорить ним и, типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Понять. В, какой ситуации успокоить себя что, все, в порядке все нормально?
Tamaz Gadaev: Джой. Страшного. Не произойдет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Мне Важно поспать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Завтра может быть пообещать себе Вот этой части, которая просит меня, что то сделать, пообещать, что точно сделаю, то, завтра выделить. Под это Время?
Tamaz Gadaev: Может, быть отказавшийся каких нибудь завтрашних вещей чтобы она, успокоилась?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, наверно. Так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Смотреть, здесь. Есть. Один момент на. Вероника слышал Такое что вечером проблемы, кажутся, гораздо, больше чем? Утром?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, это правда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Естественно, здесь это, как, утро вечером удреннее, любые, Проблемы. С утра не воспринимаются уже не, так, значимо и Здесь в, этом контексте ты. Упомянул что надо заметить и, слово, как то, себе объяснить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот Ты как?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как ты можешь сформулировать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не знаю для себя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Условно назовем. Это весомый аргумент потому что, вечером вполне вероятно тебе будут, казаться, чтобылять, меня обязательно она, сегодня поработаю. Но. Просто. Ну. Вот ну. Вот, просто капец невозможно, без, меня там, все рухнет и. Вот. Что. Здесь для, тебя, сработает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Я, грю скорее, всего это знакомая, мне процедура.
O!Sapiens Expert: К.
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Сработает. Остановиться, Взять пять минут.
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Открыть глаза и с собой поговорить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Кей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты можешь. Выбрать какое. То время когда, это станет для тебя маркером или, какой, то какой, то якорь, просто, Вот так? Вдруг вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это будет достаточно сложно сделать если. Ты. Привяжешь это к какому, то действую, или, событию это будет. Проще?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Четможды?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, было бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но мне, ну, это Такое, может. Быть уже, оверкилл, но, Мне нравится идея хотелось бы привязать это, какое. Времени?
Tamaz Gadaev: Пустим девять, вечера, или восемь, вечера?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: И делать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сессию планирования. Вечера. Что, ли. То есть, когда?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если у меня там что нибудь звенит или, не знаю меня виберирует, Вуп?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я такой?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас я пять минут, буду думать, как я буду завершать. Сегодняшний день?
O!Sapiens Expert: Отлично. Можешь настроить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Дар, так. Можно бы зарядить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но это да, без этого. Никуда?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как и всех. Нас. Хорошо, да, это тогда. Бери. И делай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть, иначе, ничего, не получится?
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть еще один, момент, в котором хочу остановиться из того разговора, который у нас был в прошлый раз, ты, сказал, Одну очень, интересную мысль которая меня зацепила, ты, сказал Что когда. Бывает, ну, такая, сложная неделя и, ты, не, высыпаешься ты, как, это, не можешь раздавать вай фай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это не знаю к это, способность делиться энергией с людьми заряжать их и, не, знаю, может быть еще такими, то другими словами, но это не какая, то метрика продуктивности всему?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как ты для себя это характеризуешь что? Это такое что? Это Значит?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это не стока метрика продуктивности?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Нет, это, скажем, так, это, можно. Выразить в продуктивность в такую руководительскую?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ты. Проще. Проще. Продавать. Идеи внутри команды какие. То чтобы, люди типа, охотно за них брались?
Tamaz Gadaev: Создавать, Какую то, что ли атмосферу в которой, всем, хорошо и мне, от этого Тоже хорошо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Я могу предположить, что то, делает лучше, Но?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Как Бой, я. Здесь не думаю про?
Tamaz Gadaev: Про погружение Это в целе стартапа. В смысле, это класно.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я, думаю, что это то, что меня, то, что мне точно помогает?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. В моей позиции?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но это больше про то, что просто кайфовее кайфовее жить наверно так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: А что в этом? Всем? Ты? Не хотел бы терять?
Tamaz Gadaev: Чтобы я не хотел терять?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я бы не хотел терять нервно айдентити человека, который, так, делает, который умеет, это делать ну и?
Tamaz Gadaev: Кого, мне Нравится быть человеком который, Ожидает вай, фай и Мне Нравится получать, из людей питбэк о том что им нравится, что, я рождаю вай фай и Очень Это такое?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, Окей И. Какие условия для того чтобы, это? У тебя сохранялось?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что, нужно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужно одержать себя в форме чтобы я мог раздавать. Вай. Фай?
O!Sapiens Expert: Трек, поподробней?
O!Sapiens Expert: Абстрактненько?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, нужно высыпаться?
Tamaz Gadaev: Держать. Уровень эндорги?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ты? Подожди, это, сколько. Часов?
Tamaz Gadaev: Уровень энергии высоким, от от семьи?
O!Sapiens Expert: От семьи?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну есть, Еще, это, компонент типа это, нужно, высыпаться в лонг терм скорей. Так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: В Шуртерме. Я не теряю ай. Дай ну смисли, я, не. Теряю. Способности. А то я, ее утеряю, в лонг терми?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это Сколько лонгтером Где у тебя граница?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что такое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Вот, если, я неделю допустим или, вы так зависит это количество. Часов сна?
Tamaz Gadaev: Допустим?
Tamaz Gadaev: Три. Дня. Подряд меньше, пяти?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это бездел. Я уже теряю все способности?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей? А, Сколько, ты потом восстанавливаешься?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Полтора, дня наверно, мне. Нужен. Хороший. День типа, отдых, какой то, в, котором, я не работаю или очень мало работаю в котором я просто тусуюсь не знаю в баню хожу и мне нужен, длительный, Сон типа часов девять?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Окей. Еще, Потом, следующий, день, у меня такой. Гроги нас пол Дня.
Tamaz Gadaev: Я бы сказал полтора дня?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, То, Есть для тебя усло на границе это три ночи по, пять, часов?
O!Sapiens Expert: И еще полтора дня?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это. Вот, все?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Есть если, другие с, этапы условные если, пять дней по шесть часов я думаю, что это тоже начинает меня как бы. Снижать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверное, какие нибудь две три недели если семь часов?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сколько Ты Готов работать без вай фая?
Tamaz Gadaev: Без вай фая?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сколько я готов работать без вай фая?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Нет, Это, сложный, вопрос мыслим?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я Готов работать без вай фая если Моя, Основная. Задача выполняется ну типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Хз Я. Могу себя представить что, я, могу на год пропасть у меня. Может. Пропасть в вай фай чтобы за год мы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не знаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Разъебали чтобы за год сделать со стартапом все что, я хочу но, а, скорее Всего того?
O!Sapiens Expert: Весь год?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но, я может быть, я, может, быть, вру.
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть Ли Готов Год не получать никакого удовольствия от жизни никих эмоций?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нет, Ну, давай, так.
Tamaz Gadaev: Есть разница, между, тем, когда вот я перестал раздавать вай фай и тем когда я, сам?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, Перестаю?
Tamaz Gadaev: Получать удовольствие. Типа. Ну. Давай, нет, давай. Так.
Tamaz Gadaev: Больше двух недель?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, нет больше двух недель. В Таком состоянии. От Хуйова Вот, У, меня сейчас было там допустим две недели и я. Все я уже понял, что типа не вариант дальше.
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверно, больше двух недель. Это Плохо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну опять Я, предполагаю, что типа, потеря, вай, фая она оправданная?
O!Sapiens Expert: Хорошо?
Tamaz Gadaev: Гостя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я скорей бы хотел сконцентрироваться на неоправданных?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ложно положительный сигнал охот, когда, Я допустим зае, бываюсь и почему, то не сплю оправданные две недели. Потери вай. Фая я толи рейд, и это принесло результат. За ну. Опять. Же, там, непонятно, там, была.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это разово было?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это было разово, И там была смесь, скорее всего, оправданных и неоправданных. Если Прям оправданная потеря вай фай на Две недели, чтобы что то там закрыть это. Какой? Ну? Ладно, Можно Так, сделать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но и больше всего меня восмущает неоправданное. Конечно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, ладно давай вернемся, к неоправданным. Ложно Положительным будь, этот, подход который ты предложил он тебе, будет, ли достаточным или, нужно что, то еще?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но я замечал, что это работает.
Tamaz Gadaev: Вспомнить Про Сон и так далее. Когда у меня на этом есть фокус?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нужна какая, то процедура в смысле либо нужно, вспоминать зачем Все это, Нужно потому что, я все могу представить когда Я сел на эти пять минут.
Tamaz Gadaev: Забил хуина Все. Типа забыл вообще зачем. Спать.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: И как то ну вот?
Tamaz Gadaev: Остался. Вот. В этом состоянии?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну короче Я, думаю. Что, то прописывание этой процедуры пятиминутной будет повязано смысле что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это все та же, привязанная клуб. В восемь вечера?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Ну, то есть, борется, два, волка да как бы, внутри один за, одно, второе, за другое, нужно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Перейти в нейтральную позицию вспомнить. Почему, Второй волк сильный типа да то? Есть, если это, проделано действительно?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тогда это сработает?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но у тебя есть понимание того, что вот сейчас ты это представляешь, тебе, кажется, это эффективный, подход, Или нужен что ты еще, туда, подкинуть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, мне. Хочется, Еще я. Знаю что уселяют второго волка введение таблички со. Сном Но я сейчас. Честно Горя не уверен?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: В то, что я то, потяну, я просыпаюсь?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня. Обычное введение. Таблички. Было привязано к тому, что я просыпаюсь, И это первые дело?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас являет ли так смогу потому, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я просыпаюсь у меня там, почти что следом идут встречи?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, Я не обычно и после этого я голодные, еще я иду. Есть, то есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: К времени. Сложно. Привязать?
O!Sapiens Expert: У тебя, когда раньше это было с таблицей у, Тебя какой, был подход ты открываешь какой то, файл, где то, и туда вносишь или, как то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, я типа, просыпаюсь. У меня. Балакает булутренняя рутина?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Утром у. Меня Ничего не происходило поэтому у, меня она была типа?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я просыпаюсь типа сразу, иду в душ, Потом возвращаюсь в душу планею, открываю, но Уто достаю табличку в табличку. Все пишу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Там?
Tamaz Gadaev: И только потом начинают день, Грубо говоря. Сейчас я, скорее, просыпаюсь у, меня есть там?
Tamaz Gadaev: Десять. Пятнадцать минут. Мне. Нужно быть навстрече?
Tamaz Gadaev: И только пятнадцать минут. Я расскачиваюсь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я понял, Мы прошлый раз, говорили, про то чтобы, сделать какую то аудиозаметку там пять секунд?
O!Sapiens Expert: С количеством сна самочувствием я подозреваю, что ты это не делал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это не делал это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Нормально, Другое. Дело что. Можем Ли мы сейчас придумать какой то, способ который будет с минимальной минимальным сопротивлением?
O!Sapiens Expert: Зиро Фрикшн?
O!Sapiens Expert: Очень простой, но как это поддержит? Волка нужного?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сейчас подумаю. Как поддержать волка в целом?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не знаю так, ли?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну. Есть, Маленькая, Вещь, очень маленькая у меня, вуп разрязан.
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай?
Tamaz Gadaev: И мне помогает.
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда первая часть дело с утра ну почти первая?
Tamaz Gadaev: Одно из первых это. Смотрю. Как я, поспал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это прикольно смысли посмотреть, что мне, там. Зеленое, не зеленое.
Tamaz Gadaev: Порадоваться, что у меня Эйчрви Высокие, или подумать. Ой Жаль, что, мне низкие?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня был прозаряжен, Я на него забил?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот я думаю, нужно вернуть вернуть рутину с лупом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
O!Sapiens Expert: Можешь?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это могу. Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, Но, Ты, Говоришь?
Tamaz Gadaev: В этом. Это Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Маленькая в. Чем где, там основное, сопротивление? Чуть надо потяжении?
Tamaz Gadaev: Нет. Маленькая, в. Смысле что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это легко. Зарядить пик и смотреть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, супер?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Лично.
O!Sapiens Expert: Тогда. Ну. Тут, делай?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Все просто?
Tamaz Gadaev: Окей Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Поможет Ли тебе то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю. Да.
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Нудо. Тестировать, Надо?
Tamaz Gadaev: Это очень. Простой способ. И увлекательный, гимифицированный возвращаться к С. К мыслям о сне хоть, как, то?
Tamaz Gadaev: Типа. Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Начинать его, трекать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, и, давай еще закрепим это. Ощущение человека который, раздавет вай фай Вот Когда Ты Оперируешь, на, Такой, максимальной своей продуктивности. Раздаешьсям Вай Фай И радуешься жизни получаешь удовольствие, и так, далее то как, это, ощущается?
O!Sapiens Expert: Общая.
Tamaz Gadaev: Блин Ну, это. Очень хорошо ощущается ну как.
Tamaz Gadaev: Заебись, ощущается, классно, где Ответите.
O!Sapiens Expert: Отлично. И вот для этого человека, и для этой идентичности. Что Значит сон?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это дисциплина. Это не наче то, что нужно, делать, или это что то, что, когда помогает быть, в ресурсе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что значит сон?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я думаю, что это часть не думает. Вообще Обо, Сня на сам деле, в смысле?
Tamaz Gadaev: Она этого спримает, как данные. Я бы так сказал?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но по. Факту, это?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну Энейблер, Это, Как, бы?
Tamaz Gadaev: То чему, по хорошему. Это часть Должна быть благодарна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: По счасть. Так?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не ощущается, то есть, игры. Я его спускаю. Это как?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как, что, то данное то, есть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Еще бывает такой прикол, что, если вот одну ночь не доспать?
Tamaz Gadaev: То этого становится больше?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Вот, но это, только, если одну ночь недоспать типа если, это уходит волоктером там Это, перестает рыбу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей А, Как можно здесь закрепить? Водосцепку со сном?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да?
Tamaz Gadaev: Здесь наверно по хорошему?
Tamaz Gadaev: Но хотелось бы вызвать чувство благодарности. Что ли?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что бы это часть сообщалась с другими частями, которые, например?
Tamaz Gadaev: Предложили поспать вовремя?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как это? Как это выстроить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Наверное, я думаю, про две часть про две вещи?
Tamaz Gadaev: Первая, если. Я не чувствую сонливость в днем?
Tamaz Gadaev: Бяже не знаю как, это в ключку пока превратить?
Tamaz Gadaev: Не чувствую сонливость. Я помню, как уела, когда мне сонливо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Туда вот. Я, прямо ну готов встроить, благодарность мысли, не чувствует сонливость, вспомнить как уего, когда, сонливо и ты такой, так круто. Что, мне не сонлива сейчас, типа, что, я могу работать вообще?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер?
O!Sapiens Expert: Можешь себе придумать, какой то ритуал когда, ты, света будешь напоминать?
Tamaz Gadaev: Тот уже сложнее чуть чуть обычное чувствую это в час.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: Сонливость?
Tamaz Gadaev: Оценка В час. Что Ли делать покуто, типа тоже вторую выберировалкун?
Tamaz Gadaev: Оценка в чанливости чтобы?
Tamaz Gadaev: Ну, как, бы ам?
O!Sapiens Expert: Закрепить ресурсные состояние?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, или не ресурсное, то есть, мое предыдущее усилие в пользу моего текущей. Энергия.
O!Sapiens Expert: Иле?
O!Sapiens Expert: Супер! Отлично?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Ну, Прикольно, мне. Нравится. Что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Как то, я всегда раньше Думал про записывание что, любые такие вещи они через, записывания делаются?
Tamaz Gadaev: На Записывание ощущается. Сейчас.
Tamaz Gadaev: Когда тяжеловестна что, ли наверно начать просто, с, того чтобы вспоминать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Рабочей, схема?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так, я смотрю на время она. Оно заканчивается а, мы с тобой говорили по поводу периодичности раз в неделю раз две недели а вопрос про раз. Две недели, Если мы сдвигаемся, то тебе кажется что, там ну, то, есть, для, тебя, весемая разница. С точки зрения эффективности. В подходе?
Tamaz Gadaev: Давай, давай, еще неделю. На следующей неделе убитости я. Бы так это сделал просто. Единственная. Проблема что?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: У меня расписание не очень?
Tamaz Gadaev: Фикст?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Tamaz Gadaev: Что там куч всякого, не на слоено?
Tamaz Gadaev: И, возможно, мне, нужно. Ноль. Час. У. Меня я пропустил один митинг, потому что остался на другом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага?
Tamaz Gadaev: Короче, мне очень удобно. Получилось?
O!Sapiens Expert: Можем в среду. Как варианты. Может быть? Ну? Тут прос, смотри. Как. У, тебя какие опции?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
Tamaz Gadaev: В среду?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы сейчас говорим про двадцать шестое двадцать, седьмое?
Tamaz Gadaev: В среду. В это же время. Как тебя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот если мы начнем сейчас, только разу, что?
Tamaz Gadaev: Если начнем сейчас?
Tamaz Gadaev: Чуть менее удобно если, В Четверг вот сейчас. Начнем?
O!Sapiens Expert: В четверг сейчас. Можно да.
Tamaz Gadaev: Час.
O!Sapiens Expert: Двадцать Седьмое?
Tamaz Gadaev: Я. Давай, секунду?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давай?
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, Давай в среду. Сейчас. Начнем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ага, Хорошо?
O!Sapiens Expert: Договорились, что тогда кинуть я, приглышелку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Все, задание, есть?
Tamaz Gadaev: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Трекинг и успех.
Tamaz Gadaev: Да, супер! Спасибо тебя?
O!Sapiens Expert: Счастливо?